THEY MIGHT EXCEPT THAT DEAL.
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS ON THE
NORTH LAWN.
AS THESE NEGOTIATIONS ARE GOING
ON, OTHER THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
A LOT OF CHANGES COMING HERE IN
THE NEW YEAR.
THE DEMOCRATS TAKE OVER THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES AND TWO
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CABINET
SECRETARIES ARE RIDING OFF INTO
THE SUNSET.
TONIGHT, INTERIOR SECRETARY RYAN
ZINKE TALKS ABOUT WHY HE'S
LEAVING AND THE CONTROVERSIES
THAT HAVE DOGGED HIM SINCE DAY
ONE.
YOU STARTED YOUR FIRST DAY IN
THE OFFICE RIDING IN A HORSE
NAMED TONTO IN JEANS AND A BLACK
COWBOY HAT.
PEOPLE KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO BE
A DIFFERENT SECRETARY OF THE
INTERIOR.
WHY ARE YOU LEAVING?
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY, WHAT'S
IMPORTANT?
INTERIOR, I LOVE OUR PUBLIC
LANDS.
THERE COMES A TIME WHEN IT'S
ABOUT RYAN ZINKE AND NOT THE
INTERIOR.
THE DISTRACTIONS OUTWEIGH THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
SO LOOKING AT IT, IT'S TIME TO
DISMOUNT.
I ENJOYED BY TIME.
I HAD A GREAT RIDE.
WE HAD A RODEO ANALOGY, GREAT
RIDE, EIGHT SECONDS, GREAT
SCORE.
I GOT OFF THE HORSE.
THERE ARE TALENTED PEOPLE THEY
CAN CONTINUE THE MISSION.
I DO NOT THINK THE MISSION IS
GOING TO CHANGE.
THE DIRECTION IS THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
>> ARE YOU FORCED OUT?
>> NO.
THE PRESIDENT, I THINK, WAS SAD
BUT UNDERSTOOD.
I HAD THE PRESIDENT -- I DO HAVE
THE PRESIDENT'S FALLS APART.
I EXERCISED WHAT THE PRESIDENT
WANTED.
>> Bret: JANUARY 22ND, USUALLY
THERE IS A TENSION BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENTS MANDATES, TO PROTECT
THE NATURAL RESOURCES, MANAGE
THEM FOR COMMERCIAL USE.
UNDER HIS
-- HOW FAST THESE
RESOURCES CAN BE AUCTIONED OFF?
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT THEY
DON'T SAY.
IS THAT WE'VE OPENED UP MILLIONS
OF ACRES FOR PUBLIC ACCESS
HUNTING AND FISHING.
WE OPENED UP 39 WILDLIFE
REFUGEES, EXPANDED WILDERNESS,
INITIATED WILDLIFE CORRIDORS.
FIRST EVER.
I'VE WITHDRAWN MINERALS IN
SENSITIVE AREAS FROM COILS AND
GAS LEASES.
WHAT THEY DON'T SAY IT IS
ACTUALLY WE ARE ONE OF THE
LEADING CONSERVATIONISTS.
NO ONE LOVES PUBLIC LAND MORE
THAN I DO.
BUT YOU CAN'T NOT MANAGE OUR
PUBLIC LANDS.
THOSE THAT WANT TO WRAP IT UP IN
BUBBLE WRAP ARE FULLY CONTENT
WITH WATCHING OUR FOREST BURNED
DOWN.
THE LEVEL OF DESTRUCTION THAT
HAS OCCURRED BY NOT MANAGING OUR
ASSETS, PARTICULARLY OUR
FORESTS?
UNPRECEDENTED.
YOU'VE GOT TO GO AND LOOK AT
PARADISE, CALIFORNIA, AND LOOK
AT THE LEVEL OF DESTRUCTION
MISMANAGEMENT CAUSED?
>> YOU'RE CONVINCED THAT'S THE
REASON?
>> THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS.
IT'S DROUGHT.
TEMPERATURES ARE RISING.
THE SEASONS GETTING LONGER.
IT DOES NOT LEAVE YOU THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO DAMAGE AS
REMOVING THE DEAD AND DYING
TIMBER.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
IT'S A MANAGEMENT ISSUE AS MUCH
AS ANYTHING ELSE.
>> YOUR CRITICS SAY YOU TURNED A
BLIND EYE TO SCIENCE WHEN IT
CAME TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
THAT, YOU REALLY SPECIFICALLY
TRIED TO CLAMP DOWN IN THIS
DEPARTMENT ON THAT ISSUE.
THIS BIG REPORT COMES OUT.
TELL ME YOUR ASSESSMENT OF THAT
REPORT?
>> I WISH THEY WOULD ACTUALLY
READ THE 1700 PAGE REPORT
BECAUSE THE REPORT ITSELF IS
PRETTY GOOD.
IT TALKS ABOUT 200 MODELS,
THERE'S OVER A THOUSAND
VARIABLES.
IF THERE IS A FLAW IN THE
REPORT, IT'S THE SUMMARY FOCUSED
ON THE CATASTROPHE.
THE REPORT LOOKED AT A FULL
RANGE OF OPTIONS.
THE MEDIA ONLY FOCUSED ON WORST
CASE EVERY TIME.
YES, WE SHOULD LOOK AT ENERGY,
BEING EFFICIENT FOR THE U.S., BY
THE WAY, WE ARE REDUCING OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT.
OUR CO2 IS DOWN, OUR METHANE IS
DOWN.
OVERALL OMISSIONS ARE DOWN.
>> Bret: AS COMPARED TO...
BE A GOAL EUROPE IS UP, CHINA IS
WAY UP, INDIA IS UP.
WE ARE GOING DOWN WHILE WE HAVE
OUR RECORD AND BREAKING OIL AND
GAS PRODUCTION.
>> Bret: YOU SEE THE DATA.
YOU BELIEVE IN MAN CAUSED
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THE
CLIMATE IS CHANGING.
IT'S ALWAYS CHANGED BUT IT'S
CHANGING IN WAYS WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
>> Bret: YOU MENTIONED THE
INVESTIGATIONS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THEM.
>> WELL, THERE IS ALLEGATIONS.
I GOT INVESTIGATED ON MY SOCKS.
>> Bret: MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN SOCKS.
>> MY WIFE IN THE SAME CAR.
WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO DO?
WHITEFISH ENERGY?
THE ONLY THING I HAVE IN COMMON
WITH WHITEFISH ENERGY IS I FROM
WHITEFISH MONTANA AND GRADUATED
FROM WHITEFISH HIGH SCHOOL.
NICE CLICKED BAIT.
SIX MONTHS LATER, EVERY
INVESTIGATION TENDS SO FAR
COMPLETED, TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION.
I FOLLOWED RULES, REGULATIONS,
NO WRONGDOING THERE THAT DOESN'T
GET REPORTED.
>> Bret: THE CASINO LOBBYING
ALLEGATION.
YOU MADE A DECISION AGAINST THE
BUREAU OF INDIAN AFFAIRS
RECOMMENDATION ON TWO CASINO
OPERATIONS BECAUSE THEY CHARGED
THAT YOU TALKS TO MGM RESORTS.
>> THE COURT AGREED WITH MY
DECISION.
AND THE DECISION WAS THIS.
SHOULD THE INTERIOR HAVE A SAY
IN JURISDICTION ON NONTRIBAL
LANDS THAT ARE HELD IN THE
FEDERAL STATE?
NO.
IF IT'S A TRIBAL LAND HELD IN
THE FEDERAL STATE, I SHOULD HAVE
A STAY.
IF IT'S NOT, THE TRIBES ARE
SOVEREIGN, THEY ARE FREE TO DO
WHAT THEY WANT.
BUT NO STATE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
DICTATE TERMS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, YES OR NO.
THE DECISION WAS UPHELD IN
COURT.
>> NATIONAL PARK SERVICE REPORT
DELETED ALL MENTION OF HUMAN
CAUSED CLIMATE CHANGE AT YOUR
DIRECTION?
>> ABSOLUTELY PATENTLY FALSE.
THAT REPORT NEVER CAME UP TO
WASHINGTON, D.C.
WE READ IT AT THE SAME TIME YOU
DID.
LOOKING UP AT IT?
IT WAS CAREERS THAT TOOK SOME OF
IT OUT, BUT IT WASN'T SOMETHING
FROM THE WASHINGTON, D.C.,
OFFICE, NOR ANY POLITICAL
APPOINTEE HAD ANY VIEW OF IT.
>> OFFICE OF SPECIAL COUNSEL
LOOKING AT WHAT THE FORMER
INTERIOR OFFICIAL REASSIGNED IN
RETALIATION FOR CRITICISM OF
YOU?
>> NO, BUT THE AUDACITY OF ANY
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE TO SAY THEY ARE
NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE -- THESE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ANGRY?
I'M NOT ANGRY.
I WAS NEVER ANGRY WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT.
I DISAGREED WITH HIS POLICIES,
BUT I WAS DISRESPECTFUL.
I WAS NEVER ANGRY.
I DIDN'T HATE PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> Bret: THERE IS THE NATIONAL
MONUMENT.
CRITICS SAY YOU WERE TAKING AWAY
THESE PUBLIC LANDS.
>> WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID DID,
HE LISTENED TO UTAH.
HE REVISED THE BOUNDARIES,
RESTORED 800,000 ACRES BACK TO
WILDERNESS, RESTORE NATIONAL
FOREST BACK TO THE NATIONAL.
>> Bret: YOU WANTED TO HAVE
THIS PLAN TO OPEN UP ALL COASTAL
WATERS TO OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS
DRILLING.
EVENTUALLY HE WAS AN EXCEPTION
FOR FLORIDA.
SOME PEOPLE SAID, THAT'S A
POLITICAL EXEMPTION TO HELP RICK
SCOTT.
>> HERE'S WHAT OCCURRED.
IF THEY'LL MAKE THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION TOOK 95% OFF OUR
COAST LINE OFF THE TABLE FOR OIL
AND GAS.
WE LOOKED AT IT, LET'S OPEN IT
UP, LET'S TALK TO THE COASTAL
COMMUNITIES, THE GOVERNORS, THEN
MAKE IT RIGHT.
WITH FLORIDA, THERE IS A
MILITARY MORATORIUM IN LAW
AGAINST OIL AND GAS DRILLING.
IF THERE IS ONE THING THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE WITH THE
INTERIOR IS WE HAVE GIVEN BACK
TO THE COMMUNITY VOICE, THE
STATE'S VOICE, AND WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT, LANDS MANAGEMENT,
OUR PARKS, RECREATION
OPPORTUNITIES.
OIL AND GAS TOO.
>> Bret: I'VE HEARD
CONSERVATIVES SAY THEY THINK
ENVIRONMENTALIST, VERY ACTIVE
ONES LEADING THE CHARGE AGAINST
SCOTT PRUITT AND AGAINST YOU --
THERE WAS SOME FIRE BEHIND THIS
MODE.
WITH YOU, YOU'RE SAYING THERE'S
NOTHING TO IT.
DO YOU BELIEVE IT'S AN
ORCHESTRATED EFFORT BECAUSE OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL LOBBY?
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT IT'S
COORDINATED.
THERE ISN'T ANYTHING THERE.
THERE NEVER HAS BEEN.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY UPFRONT, I DID
WEAR M AGA SOCKS.
YES, I WORE THE SOCKS WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S FACE ON IT.
GUILTY AS CHARGED.
>> DRAIN THE SWAMP!
>> Bret: THAT PRESIDENT
CAMPAIGNED ON DRAINING THE
SWAMP.
HIS CRITICS WILL SAY THE SWAMP
GOT BETTER OF HIM AND SOME
PEOPLE IN HIS ADMINISTRATION
BECAME THE SWAMP.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> WHEN YOU START TRAINING THE
SWAMP, IT STARTS EXPOSING THE
SURFACE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE A
MAGNIFICENT JOB OF DRAINING THE
SWAMP, BUT THIS IS -- THIS IS A
BATTLE FOR AMERICA'S FUTURE.
THE SWAMP, THE POWER IN D.C. IS
CORRUPTIVE.
AFTER 30 YEARS OF SERVICE, 23
YEARS, A COMMANDER IN THE
SEAL TEAM SIX, STATE SENATOR,
U.S. CONGRESSMAN, A SECRETARY,
I'VE NEVER SEEN THE LEVEL OF
ANGER, OF HATRED, THEY HAVE
THREATENED MY WIFE, MY FAMILY,
TRESPASSED MY -- THEY HAVE LIED,
CHEATED, MADE FALSE ALLEGATIONS.
THIS COUNTRY NEEDS TO TAKE A
DEEP BREATH AND UNDERSTAND WE
ARE ALL AMERICANS.
>> THIS IS, I THINK, THE BEST
DEAL IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
IT EXTENDS FROM THE CAPITAL ALL
THE WAY TO THE ARLINGTON
NATIONAL CEMETERY.
IN MOST PEOPLE SEE THE MAJESTY
OF THE MONUMENTS.
SECRETARY, WHAT I SEE, AND
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
BACKLOG AND REPAIR.
WE ARE PRIORITIZING.
OUR PARKS ARE NOT REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT.
THEY ARE AMERICAN.
THEY ARE RED, WHITE, AND BLUE.
>> Bret: ARE YOU GOING TO MISS
THIS?
>> I AM.
I'M GOING TO -- UNTIL I GET OFF